guys whoa I'm Greg I'm John rings
trailer number two she's beautiful I
have a ticket there once was a girl no
one dares speak her name SWA and death
she seeks vengeance life filled with
pain once you see her story
[Music]
you have seven days to live whoa not
forget and she does not forgive I
surprisingly enjoyed that trailer a lot
more than the first I really enjoyed
that the first one felt very much like a
trailer yeah for a movie that's not
being represented right I don't like a
trailer for it deep like for a videotape
right but I like straight to DVD I like
having a little was what she saying not
like a poem well yeah it's like a little
fairy tale yeah I really [ __ ] up a
little fairy tale that's a different
vibe to have for the ring movie to bring
that forward and to make it you know I
think that's a really good choice cuz it
is you know a little ghostly fairy tale
and yeah I like that they're embracing
that and it comes out in the style to
like there's that one shot that's like I
guess inside the videotape were like the
colors are all warped out like some kind
of yeah 90s expressionist nightmare like
those those things I think are cool I
like that this trailer gets us back to a
you know dready chilling ghost story
atmosphere old early oh I could see why
you work for bloom house thank you talk
about horror really well cuz even that
like like this the the stuff that's
upsetting about this looks more visceral
and I like that cuz in the first trailer
it looked a little more like heightened
and wagon that shot where she's pulling
where it's like POV pulling the hair out
of her mouth like that's pretty
unsettling yeah this looks like a pretty
disturbing film honestly it has
everything I like in the first ring
movie you know it's going back to that
whole like seven days and they're gonna
do a lot of like scary shit's happening
up until day 7 i'm assuming like the
visual cues they have for it or really
neat like that Shaw were the guys like
looking in the window then like a flash
of lightning happens and he just sees
the forest with the well there ya has a
really crazy shot yeah I was it looks
like a very visually impressive shock
you got the cool creepy shots of Samara
you got flashback shots of Samara you
got like the creepy like body Lee horror
stuff you
are coming out of the TV and then you
got like cool visual cues for like
awesome flat horror flashes to occur
well I like when they go with the sort
of ambiguous universe thing it's not
like a remake but it is just kind of
another ring story as far as I'm getting
the impression anyway I think it's cool
they're doing because they're adding
little rules and stuff like that to the
like when she takes off her shirt she's
got the scar um and that's almost you
know it's a little more aggressively
like barkery to me totally I mean the
acting of it still doesn't look as on
pars like the first ring nor the
meanwhile there's Naomi what while
there's cool like visual flares at here
the overall cinematography doesn't look
as captivating as the first one either
but I still feel like that if it went
for if they have honor the tone of this
trailer like what the trailer is
marketing as with a cool little creepy
like role given a fairytale dialogue
that would be really neat to have that
kind of tone over it yeah because it
would give us something different and
even amp up the whole Samara image or
Samara where I don't give a [ __ ] how you
say it Sam Sanders because some some
entering game of thrones or lower the
Rings their comment and especially you
know with with sonico vs kakoe going
much more like fun and crazy about it I
think it would be nice if this got back
to that simple chilling ghost story vibe
and the thing is yeah like watching this
I don't know if it's gonna be great but
this trailer makes me want to see it
yeah februari third man then after that
fab 3 is the shades darker yeah one week
later yeah get it all oh do we get every
movie we've wanted februari hey buddy if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe today please it would make us
happy it would it might make you a
little bit you know piss your butthole a
little bit John is reason to Jerry on
Twitter Instagram he's also the social
media manager of Facebook and bloom
house a lot of horror movie stuff he
likes to cover yeah and I want to give a
shout out to chance cook the you now
Pete Mangione get the shoutouts chance
cook he go to you over 4,000 bars to us
so Connie
chance that I've done that for us man I
won't stick a chance cooking meth oh
yeah it did not go down well no I lost
my family my wife had a we just had a
baby she took her away my son who
suffers from cerebral palsy that right
I'm sorry I was trying to go on he you
know doesn't even talk to me anymore my
best friend was a cop died it's all
because I took a chance on cook yeah man
oh and her on the one who comes know